let's shift to the election more
explicitly now and Paul you recently
commented on FBI director James Comey
'he's reopening of the clinton email
scandal in the times in your times
column you wrote it was worse than
bizarre it was outrageous mr. Comey
apparently had no evidence suggesting
any wrongdoing by Hillary Clinton he
violated long-standing rules about
commenting on politically sensitive
investigations close to an election and
he did so despite being warned by other
officials that he was doing something
terribly wrong with a few days hindsight
here what do you think is going on and I
wonder if Hillary Clinton is elected
president how long this persists oh wow
so nobody really knows what's going on
it's actually awesome how Comey has gone
dead silent ever since no attempts to
justify no nothing is this was I mean
the best guess is that he was bullied by
by Republican congressman who who were
never satisfied because he didn't bring
charge you know it just it look it was
incredible it was it was something that
all the old norms are breaking down and
we're seeing now the FBI seems to be
full of people who just don't understand
their responsibilities I don't know what
happens with co me I somebody said if if
he visits the White House after Clinton
is elected that you know any order
glasses will turn into into icicles
instantly but but what's going to happen
clearly as if she has elected
Republicans will you know they'll begin
impeachment proceedings probably before
she even enters office so but what why
do you why are you so sure that it was
due to Republican bullying there this
invest their this this laptop was wasn't
it sort of in play for a while wasn't
there some indication there was
something in the background I mean but
you knew nothing I mean they have no
idea what's on the laptop and you don't
mean there are all kinds of things that
we are pretty reliably informed that the
FBI has an investigation into Trump's
aids connections with Russia they
decided we aren't going to bring that up
because we're too close to an election
now now who we here have something which
has nothing there was nothing he said
there is a laptop which has some emails
which may or may not be new information
and this gets announced in a tersely
worded statement that left open the
implication this was this was just
absolutely on bonkers I'd like to follow
up on something that Dave
touched on though and what this means
let's let's say Hillary Clinton gets
elected what does it mean for her
ability to govern well that's going to
be really interesting if she doesn't if
she has a Democratic Senate at least
she'll be able to fill the vacancy on
the Supreme Court that make appointments
if she doesn't have that God knows but
legislation I mean all indicate mean
President Obama has been unable to pass
any legislation since his first two
years since he lost lost the house to
Republicans and there's no reason to
think that we different so America is
perilously close to you know to a failed
state here we are this rich
sophisticated country where everything
works pretty well and we have a
government that is almost incapable of
functioning and ain't going to get
better